citizens of the reject nation as you may have
heard of late things are a little bit uh rocky
over at warner brothers dc we've got a lot of
announcements we've heard a lot of cancellations
we've heard a lot about reboots we've got
movies still coming out we've got movies in
post-production there's a lot going on but i think
there is a solution that they might do that would
solve the reboot problem the matt reeves batman
problem and make the current fans of the dc eu
happy and it's all comic book canon this is that
journey i'm gonna explain it all but first please
leave a like leave a comment let me know what you
think about this grand reboot idea that'll be very
interesting for all parties involved please do
hit that subscription bell it'll notify you of
other videos just like this one also please
follow me on tik tok where i give all sorts
of 15 second 30 second one minute three minute
short form versions of videos just like this
full of comic nerd savvy and to talk about movies
and stuff let's dive into how to reboot the dceu
so with batgirl cancelled and black adam flash
shazam aquaman joker 2 peacemaker season 2 and
another few things up in the air we've heard david
zasloff does want an mcu-esque 10-year plan going
forward looking to reboot the dc universe but with
certain things in production certain other things
in post-production certain things with release
dates what does that look like how do you reboot
while also making the og fans happy and how do
you do that with the matt reeves batman carrying
on which it does seem to be now there is a comic
solution to this and i think would be the strength
of both dc and marvel i think this would utilize
everything marvel is doing well but also be the
strength that dc has had the last few years now
personally one of the things i've really enjoyed
about dc is that they've let the movies live and
breathe on their own i like personally that the
shazam movie felt like an old amblin film mixed
with comic book elements and the batman movie
felt like a david fincher film those movies would
never work in the same universe i also enjoyed the
fact that i could watch peacemaker that could
be rated r and that felt completely separate of
everything except the suicide squad i do honestly
think batman and joker in those separate movies
never meeting was a strength of dc because that's
a lot like the comic books there are different
continuity but when you've got marvel when you've
got the strength of marvel you make it that you
can't miss a film right it's an installment
it's almost a long form tv series if you
miss an episode you'll get what's going on but it
won't be as fulfilling so marvel has made a lot of
must-watch television through disney plus as well
as must-watch movies where you care about every
single character on the roster at least enough
to go see it in theater i understand why the dc
universe wants to mirror the strengths of marvel
marvel looked at the greater mcu and went hey
this is only so sustainable if we don't let the
directors make their vision if everything feels
similar to each other that can be a pro anacon and
multiverse madness let sam raimi for the most part
make a giant sam raimi film but marvel fans got
a little fan entitlement and wanted more more
of what the trailer showed which was a lot of the
multiverse stuff we'd already seen now that's a
tricky line to walk because marvel's trying to
give the fans they want they listen to the fans
they read the message boards they're very engaged
but inherently you can't give everyone everything
they want if you're living in this one big sandbox
you can't let sam raimi make a full-on sam raimi
film and also have it be the multiverse madness
that a lot of fans expect and i think that was
also somewhat of an issue with the taiko a td
film having it be so versed in comedy and drama
but also being a thor film that has to carry on
the mcu so what i would do is i would make one
more dceu film i would have black adam and shazam
duke it out and maybe have a shazam 3 or a black
atom two were that got brought together i would
leave that over here i know they've got scenes of
the snyder films in that movie but that personally
would be its own thing i would have aquaman and
the flash come out if they want the flash to come
out have that be the last thing leading especially
since that's a flashpoint movie to a crisis on
infinite earths now in the comic books this is
how you reset continuity dc has done it a number
of times after a long enough run of comic books
people get sick of a certain idea people get
sick of a character acting a certain way people
get sick of this longer run on continuity it's
very intimidating sometimes to buy an issue 612
sometimes you want to go buy an issue number one
if a comic's been running for a certain amount of
time the number feels intimidating to dive into
and the characterization feels intimidating to
try to invest it so you reboot and the way dc does
that is through this crisis concept do that with
the movies make one more movie and make it be
the secret wars that i think we're leading to
in marvel but for dc and they've already done
this on tv there was a crisis event on tv that
was very successful and if you do this for the
movies bring henry cavill back have that one more
appearance of superman have your multiple batmans
with michael keaton and ben affleck have all the
things we've wanted to see these characters get to
do much like the snyder cut have that big epic and
bring in the tv show characters i almost guarantee
stephen amell would come back to play arrow if
it's in a movie that brings all this together i
almost guarantee that after season nine of flash
which feels kind of convenient grant gustin could
play this character one more time we'd get this
big moment have an epic event the likes of which
we're getting in a few years of secret wars spend
the money spend the i know it's going to be insane
like 250 million dollars but the way you wrap that
movie is you have the biggest hall h or fandom
announcement of all time by having that continuity
wiped out and have a new 52-esque team introduced
at the end of that movie have your cast of the new
universe revealed in a giant new justice league
that way the way dc wants to run into things is
by having you know their justice league movie from
the jump we saw with the last iteration they did
man of steel right into batman v superman right
into justice league have the justice league fully
formed we all know batman's origin i don't need
to see another set of pearls break we all know
who superman is but we don't want to see the same
iteration if they want to reboot give them a comic
canon reboot that takes place right at the very
end and there's your new characters and then what
you do is you have a universe that's the justice
league shared universe dceu in the truest sense
have a dc extended universe that a lot of people
have wanted that it sounds like david saslov wants
a shared universe a lot of the mcu but what
you can do with a crisis on infinite earths
is you also keep over here a disjointed dc black
label universe in the comic books there's an
entirely different imprint and the books are as
actually physically different they don't look
like regular comic books some of them do most of
them are more of an album shape they're squared
off they feel like more of a book and it's a
comic book that's r-rated is a black label book
that's a completely different continuity it's
all the same characters but it's not the same
continuity and they typically are darker here is
where you have matt reeves batman where you have
todd phillips joker where you continue the shazam
and black adam storyline where you keep going
with lastic man's story that we've been teased for
years have the directors get to make their vision
with their individual characters and literally
just call it something else call it the black
label films call it dc something else and you have
what dc's been doing incredibly which is letting
directors share their vision over here and then
you've got the shared universe of dc characters
in this justice league film and you reboot
however you choose now what i'm hoping they do
is they have green lantern exist over here as the
space cop is meant to be that character should
never interact with robert pattinson's batman
nor should he necessarily interact with black
adam you also have a new batman and superman that
don't have the history of them having fought yes
batman and superman fought in the comic it didn't
make sense then in that medium and that medium
is a lot more forgiving it's a guy fighting an
all-powerful alien it's a rich dude i know there's
that cannon of if batman had long enough to plan
he could beat anybody it doesn't make sense that
bruce wayne could even fight to a sand still with
clark kent it doesn't make sense what you do what
i would do is have the already established world
of gods that the dc represent and you have batman
as our eye line he's the guy that's looking around
at this world that he's trying to navigate he's
the world's greatest detective he's the smartest
guy have your new batman trying to navigate this
world of dc it's not gonna be fun to lose this
incredible team of of actors and filmmakers like
jason momoa and gal gadot and all these people
but if you're gonna reboot do it from a place
where everyone's on the same page and then do what
marvel has been doing in their phase three four
and going forward have a movie come out a quarter
have this all scheduled out have a 10 year plan
that literally introduces these characters in a
crisis event and then one movie come out after
another hit that winter movie hit the spring
hit the summer hit the fall and then grow at
universe quickly but have these characters already
established because we don't need another origin
but again shared universe here dc black label here
have your cake and eat it too let one universe
be shared let one universe be this director's
vision and that way you literally thrive in both
realities i think a crisis movie could give us
all this i think i want to see more of peacemaker
i think i want to see more of matt reeves batman
i think i want to see two separate universes and
this is something they can do if they just make
one more movie and that movie is already comic can
so i think in your one shared universe you lean
into the easter eggs you lean into this shared
world you lean into all the things does make the
mcu thrive and in the other universe you have
that guillermo del toro justice league dark movie
we never got we get all these other opportunities
and i think that's what we need to look at these
movies as is this is an adaptation of a comic book
it's not a translation of a comic book the
comic book medium allows for more suspension
of disbelief because you're the one painting the
moving pictures when you look at a comic book the
space between the panels is your imagination your
creativity when you look at a movie that's someone
showing you their vision of the story that someone
painting the picture for you they're giving you
this delivery you need to understand that when
you're making a shared universe and i think that's
the benefit of starting over is knowing that going
forward allows you to make things so it's not as
unbelievable as batman and superman fighting
so it's not as disparate as someone that's a
street level somehow just now encountering green
lantern make a universe where the suspension of
disbelief is equal across all the justice league
characters and then make another universe where
zatanna makes as much sense as plastic man as much
sense as matt reeves batman and all those things
have one disconnected intentionally have one
connected intentionally have your cake eat it
too have a good time gonna give you some comic
recommendations now i'm only going to give you
three but this is for the main three this is the
trinity of dc you're batman you're superman or
wonder woman i think the tone they should try to
land with is with batman go with the new 52 batman
go with scott snyder's batman lean into the court
of owl's flavor he'll do the court of owls story
i think they'd be a great first movie for this
batman i know they might be doing quarterbacks
matt reeves batman but i want to establish gotham
as somewhere near metropolis but not in metropolis
i want them to establish batman as a guy that's
aware of the greater world around them that can
also have his own independent movies he needs to
know clark kent's out there but it doesn't need
to be his every waking moment for wonder woman i
would do the george perez omnibus this is a story
of gods this is the story of powerful women this
is a story of bounty this book is gorgeous and
it's also who i see diana prince as and i really
think they need to establish diana prince in this
world we need again her to be her own character
but also be able to team up with these other very
different worlds and then lastly i really think
that superman needs to be superman he needs to be
the boy scout he is he needs to be someone that
knows his biggest flaw is that he can't save
everyone superman is the most powerful creature
on earth but it's physically impossible even with
super speed and super hearing to hear everyone's
cry for help and stop and save everything i think
superman red and blue jeff loeb tim sale captures
superman's weakness isn't just kryptonite it's
the fact that he can't be everywhere and that's
really important i want a superman that feels
like someone you can meet and look up to but his
inherent flaws that he just can't do it all i want
superman's burden to be that give me those those
are your comic recommendations check them out
what do you guys think about my reboot into
universe idea what do you think about keeping
one universe darker and separate versus keeping
one all tied together what do you guys think
about the reboot in general and do you want a
crisis on infinite earth's bringing the tv shows
the movies together bringing these actors back
having one big blowout and ending them i want
henry cavill back at least once give him give
me give me superman back all right you lovelies
that's gonna do it for this episode i appreciate
the hell out of each and every one of you leading
to new gods mr miracle movie dark universe give me
that all right read some comics i'll see you soon